Suppose, I've got a depth scene here and
I'd like to match it to some model or
some previously observed depth scene.
How might I do that?
Well, what I need to do,
is I need to find some patches,
some locations on my object and match
them to some locations on my object.
And you know it should be somewhat
invariant to how I look at it.
All right, so I'm looking over here,
looking over there.
I want to find the same thing,
the object might be rotated.
Things might,
we've seen this movie before.
Remember we we're matching pictures as
we had two pictures that were rotated,
translated, scaled, and
we wanted to align them.
Do you remember SIF?
SIF was a way of saying,
in Harris points, remember they were
Harris Stevens points, and
nobody ever remembered Stevens.
We had ways of finding points, and
then generating a descriptor and
that descriptor had to be,
sort of discriminative and yet, robust.
That is, we wanted them to be
relatively unique but robust, so
that when we found a description
here and we matched it with
the description there,
it would most likely be the right one.
And then we improve that,
we use ransack in order to find
the right sets of matches.
Well, we can do exactly
the same thing with depth.
You know what's drawn here is that
I've got this interest point and
I've got this sort of neighborhood
of these five points around it or
I might look at a, at a volume of these.
And what I'm going to do it, I might
find the relationship between these
points and say the little local
normals associated with the point, or
something to do with the geometry.
The idea is whatever it is that
I'm measuring is not a function
of how I looked at the points.
So in fact, the way we often do these
is, we typically will build a, we'll,
we'll take these points and
we'll build a, a description and
we'll put them into a histogram.
Okay, so maybe we just quantized these
different orientations into, you know,
five different levels, so we have,
you know, five, level thing, and
then we might have distances.
So, in fact, one example,
they used a five by five by five
histogram that gave you 125
different values, okay?
Remember in SIF I think we
had 128 different values.
So here we have 125 different values.
And then for every patch,
we compute these and
we can compare them against the patches
in our model, find the putative matches,
and then do something like ransack to,
to do the matching.
There's a version called
the fast point feature histogram
which is a way of doing this in 3D,
and again,
I think is probably influenced
directly in the Point Cloud Library.
So there are a couple of places
where the Point Cloud Library, I,
I already pointed you
at 'PointClouds.org'.
For many of you in the robotics
universe there's something called ROS,
the Robot Operating System originally
out of Willow Garage and then it's,
it's robotic software open found,
it's got all those letters in it,
it's an open source ongoing development
system for doing robotics and
the Point Cloud Library and
by the way, Open CV,
Computer Vision Library
are all part of that universe.
And that's really helped make it easy
for people to do that development.
And there are drivers, by the way,
in that for using the Kinect or
PrimeSense sensors as well, so you can
go get your point clouds that way.
So here's a picture that I showed
you before from pointclouds.org.
And in fact, here it says,
ransack cylinder segmentation.
So basically, they ransacked to
find the different planes and
to also find these different cylinders.
You know how to do that already,
so you could do this and
it basically gives you a direct
interpretation of the geometry